the Joe Rogan experience there's a lot
of people that they learn how to deal
with life through the struggle of
jujitsu because the struggle of training
is so much harder than most of struggles
that you face in your daily life it
makes you more accustomed to dealing
with uncomfortable engines out there
funny story that washes you to dust for
you I my my older daughter had some
health issues I get two o'clock in the
morning something like that and I called
the doctor and said look I've gotta go
and get this inhaler something at the
pharmacy man I was wearing my pajamas
driving crazy to the pharmacy and as I'm
walking in have a guy walking out and
bumping his shoulder - hey son of ideas
a few and turning them one wanna fight
go home go Joe what dude
then they got number wait for you then
his outside ago got the medication I put
the stuff in semi Gallagher sod he's no
longer there several months later the
same guy show up in my school and I did
not recognize him but he keep staring at
me and I approached hey how are you
unhappy trend sheets before I was like
do you remember me did you train here
before no I bump into you in the
pharmacy
I hate girl like thank you for not
hurting me man what happened to you that
all my father passed away a day before I
was so depressed so the point for me was
with you Jitsu I can walk away for
something like that didn't I feel sorry
for the guy
yeah I'm not concerned oh I'm afraid of
him no I'm not afraid it's just a fact
that I'm saving him to get hurt right
today he is one of my best friends
he's my lawyer my dear friend he's been
training it for since that time almost
as 20 years but I remember that day
walking in and the guy brought in to me
I wanna fight Wow anything man I walk
away no no no you too strong for me man
go home and
yes that's the difference - between
jiu-jitsu and kickboxing because the
kickboxing you you can only hurt
somebody you can't really like hold on
no hey hey you ever see this already
hurts man you ever see the video you
ever see the video of Matt Serra Matt
Serra was in an altercation with some
drunk guy in a bar or a restaurant
okay so Danny why Matt just took the guy
down mounted him and just just hold it
onto his wrist and he was like calm down
calm down and the employers are like
trying to figure out what to do is like
he's fine he's fine calm down but you
know Matt didn't hurt him he just held
on to him and basically just mounted him
and grabbed ahold of his wrist and was
controlling of it
I mean when we say jiu-jitsu is a gentle
art yeah we mean that yes jiu-jitsu will
give you the choice to choose to hurt
someone or not yeah and I think my
trainee realized that that person has
something already going on in their life
right and we choose not to
yeah I mean we grew up in our time and
that's fine with teenagers in know she
shoots at tournaments and then we go
like how are we gonna test ourself and
back in the day it is in Brazil we have
some fun time we go to a nightclub and
fight breaks through and here we are
practicing Jitsu but not hurting anybody
and not because we choose or somebody
provoke no we get people coming towards
us because we always little guys we're
never my biggest guys in the place then
we just make sure like man we take them
down hold choke somebody out but no
scratch and on the end those people
become students of our school right how
those little kids can do that to us
right and that's one way that's funny in
the eighties that jiu-jitsu became even
bigger with some of the altercation on
the street we convinced the person that
we just fought we just choked to come
and become our student because he didn't
hurt them then they ended up coming in
like that they feel humiliated but at
least they they feel thankful that you
didn't injure them for sure yeah
in unifying and that I think is you to
give you that sense of control yes there
you have you have that choice this is
where I always explain to people I say
if I'm in a street fight with someone
and they're swinging if it's strong
person as a strong person they're good
athlete they have strong arms and then
they're throwing punches at me if I get
hit I'm in trouble no matter who you are
if you get hit you're in trouble most
likely I won't get hit if I know how to
how to fight and I keep my hands up and
I move right but if I get a hold of you
you're not doing anything to me like
there's a difference between like
someone who's untrained and someones
trained like if a jiu-jitsu blackbelt
grabs a person and gets off it actually
gets control of them there's no lucky
you're not gonna luckily submit me you
know it's not gonna happen but you can
luckily you could hit someone it can
happen in a street fight if someone has
a little bit of speed and they have
power and there's a strong person they
can hit you it's much more than in and
that's the only and we also wanted
training was the only opportunity our
opponent has is before we close the
distance right that's the danger zone
and if you think for a second a lot of
things that we do on the ground in
jiu-jitsu you just bring those two
people up in the close distance is the
same thing mmm and a lot of people today
they don't do the same they tried to
fight standing when they hold different
than when you're on the ground the way
you move your legs away play guard it's
the same thing when you're standing work
on the people's body as a hook as a
sweep to make somebody fall and and we
learned that when we get close to
someone we make this size not be
affected as much as could if you have a
distance